early helicopter life Megan's gonna make
me put you on it like a visible a stupid
parity muscle like my name is Gary Vee
stop I've been telling you I'm triple
A's having a pedigree I mean and a
special my specialty
I'm putting the works and I'm Jevon
and one got that love I just think it's
worth the risk
I don't care if you're somebody that
uses big data and you're gonna
synthesizing it I don't care if you're
the greatest natural talent like I am
and you just live life and it just comes
to you I just don't care what your
process is it's just get me to the
insights right get me to the thing right
to me I don't know what brand strategy
you know it's Karen
twenty-seven-year-old she has two cans
or it's a it's the manifesto from the
brand or if it's like find it here's
what I know every piece of business
needs us to find the white space the
prop the problem the problem with either
or or anything we come up with is the
humans are gonna break it so let's start
let's start let's let's start with that
let's start that no matter what we
decide here it will not work and I'm
being dead serious what I mean by that
is it's what human beings do it's what
they do
depending on their level of ego and
pride humility and thought like teamwork
so I think my job at the at the top of
the spear is to give thought to things
that position less friction not more and
I'm not saying having an overarching
idea is that but but that is the only
filter I'm going through thank you guys
that helped me
that progression we're always talking
about can you think of any brands to off
the top of your head that have just died
out because radio television the first
wave or TV whatever that's like uh TV to
phone well you know what you can say
it's happening now
[Music]
cool
not gonna be a lot you're gonna show
that but if you could like might want to
be able guys we're gonna play music over
what just happened but it was [ __ ]
brilliant okay we'll listen then I'll be
frank with you like if that's the case
then that's and that's what I'll do so
I'm gonna go to Alan's office right now
literally walk out of mine are you sup
stranger guys it's d-roc he does other
things how was your date astray let's go
out the episode
[Music]
love both ideas in their life of Hemnes
extended to print everything can extend
this course and if it can show us both
ideas in print and then that will help
us decide which one I say okay good can
you tell them that they should be they
should really really consider running
both in print on face book against the
actual consumers that they want to buy
it and read the quant and qual data
against it just tell them that as well
tell them I walked in and said this yes
this do your thing have you thought
about how smart it would be to spend
fifty thousand dollars to have these two
pictures $25,000 Media spend we don't
have to do it we I don't even know what
their [ __ ] MSA is like we just want
to tell them what the plan against I
don't know if it you know on 27 to 42
year-old moms with families and put run
them and then read the quant and qual
data because that would also give them a
data point of the actual end consumer
for this debate three seconds left
should say to watch the whole thing
go to facebook.com nope
three seconds take over the whole
[ __ ] thing not know how respectfully
but people don't want to go to brand
you'll lose you'll lose eighty to ninety
percent of the thing because nobody
wants to go to a brand's website but
they'll go to Facebook and I actually
think the way to do it is to say go to
Facebook and search then you guys you
just have to see how it's coming up yeah
so just jumped in you've got a huge new
client so I jumped in a refill in it
nice job
make sure you blur out the stuff huge
new client so it seems excited I'm
excited a big new brand in the building
big new holding company in the building
key moments that's where I like to come
in and sprinkle I think managers and
CEOs do really poor job and they want to
bake the cake and put the icing on and
the sprinkles and the cherry and that's
called micromanaging it's just a bad
idea
to me I want to be in the cherry
business right like I believe in my team
go make the cake
go make the icing go make the sprinkles
I'm just gonna put the greatest [ __ ]
sherry you've ever seen on that cake
that's good
read a book called crush it how'd you
get any of it
my dad was into it my dad is the one my
dad's a huge mentor to me much like your
dad has to you and he's the one who told
me about I was like that I'm not really
into reading though ya know I don't I
hate to read get me to take you
challenge for me so to me the things I
think most about are number 1 2 3 & 4 is
to build self-esteem so my belief is
that self-esteem is the only drug that
combats the world yeah I genuinely
believe horrible in parallel it's
imperative that you don't build fake
self esteem self esteem can't be
manufactured through rewarding non
rewarding events if you versus
participation trophies correct you can't
come in eighth place in the race and
school and then get prized for that
because that's just not real life
however Xander for example this weekend
when Max got heard his nephew stopped
what he was doing and came over and
showed amazing empathy for a
four-year-old that has become now the
thing I've talked to him about for two
days
yeah but he's incredible that you have
such a great heart like to me you triple
down this is by the way this is me being
a byproduct of being what I think
perfectly parented this is what my mom
did yeah my mom over-exaggerated my
natural goodness as a person to make me
believe it was like the most important
thing and she never gave me third place
trophies and when I lost I lost and she
made me realize there were repercussions
in life so when I got bad grades even
though she knew I was gonna be very
special
I was literally punished subconsciously
I knew that it wasn't the most important
thing in the world but I do like that
she punished me and didn't let me
completely disrespect the system but she
never let it hurt my confidence
right she played it very spot and there
is something interesting my parents did
at 14 and they said look tough guy
you're not gonna be a student paints are
gonna work and so that means you're
gonna start working now and so I do
think one of the great things my parents
did I think a lot of parents should
think about this is if you don't have a
student even if they're an artist and
want to sing and paint we need to figure
out how to establish massive work ethic
because the only thing that's
controllable for somebody who's gonna
bet on themselves in life is their work
ethic their talent you can get it better
right you can lift more you can get
better at things but something like my
calves an ass art naturally the the same
as everybody else and there's people are
naturally like I don't like my chest is
never gonna be as big as I necessarily
want it because there's certain things
that are right but meanwhile like mouths
sell you back the hat you're wearing
right now I will and so I think that I
think it's important to teach work ethic
because worth that work ethic is the
only thing that maximizes what you
naturally have and that's really the
best you can ask for
I mean this is my new favorite office
juice cheese how are you remind me oh my
god yeah yes yeah I see the end of the
month
I remember here I want to apologize to
you really fast mad at you I hit your
shoulder in a weird way and I hit you
throw what's amazing I'm so I'm so I'm
so amazingly strong now that I don't
remember that so my big thing right now
is Facebook long for videos influencers
on Instagram and what I would call
hacking culture anything that can
penetrate and create noise in a million
different things that could mean a
million different things for my personal
brand not my brands and other things
that means that I genuinely believe that
hip-hop is the seed of our culture I
just genuinely believe that and I think
it's a good use of my time
especially when I'm lucky enough to have
somebody like Mike Boyd in my life right
where he just genuinely has a great
track record and of course the rock and
these guys are always looking at Spotify
and SoundCloud and like every youngster
you know spends time trying to find new
artists and different stuff of that
nature I just play the same Lionel
Richie song over and over like what
everybody people love discovery but I am
very fascinated by what's happening in
the cross-section of the two places
you're playing my dream to give you as
much value right now as possible so that
when you do become massive you're like
Gary Vee was always there I mean it's
not super complicated it's it's that
truly basic for me let me hop in the
coop get a shot at the goose to the top
at the booth
it's in the past from the top visible in
another second nobody hit the booth
juice but I hate this new dad and I'm
blowing your waste by the thousand
pattern ladies do with me you're paid by
the ounce that's I've been painting
about later said dad Mike blabs and you
like me now said a pretty good my
pecking on the way by the pound you
should be like but that's it the word
waiting I'm fat [ __ ] the chip that
he's dating way down there with way over
there baby
much loved everybody wants to shout out
to you oh my man how are you come in who
are you boys it's a pleasure
oh thanks tank we love it I'll call you
whatever you [ __ ] me I'll call you
whatever you want tell me which was good
for him terribly
so you know taught me to do that I could
do anything a hundred percent like doing
stand-up hundred percent 100 percent so
any sales situation I found myself in
it's nothing like nothing yeah we feel
the knife don't have to give me money
hundred percent but the problem with
stand-up is I was sitting on the jokes
for like a week two weeks a month don't
like you get to microphone so the energy
would just die so what means happened I
was like this is sick I can make a joke
find a picture make a joke get it out to
people get feedback and go from there on
to the next thing so for somebody like
me who's always going it's what means
right timing whatever course it's just
been good but my Instagram take Sinatra
is like just taking off in a way they
feel so awesome it's crazy
it really is how many your app now 850
you know amazing how often are you
showing your face on the texts natural
count on a story pretty regularly how
about on the posts on the post like once
a month maybe change it yeah tomorrow
here's how I ready ready my yeah
ready yeah minimum stick with me minimum
yeah minimum
like you're much bigger than me but I'm
not gonna let you get away with that
minimum once a week minimum
okay so [ __ ] how long how many posts
today are you doing
yeah I would tell you that if I could
help it
I would have you do it once every two
days yeah and you know what I would do
straight to face video and I would just
have you do your thing yeah if you can
actually do stand-up yeah [ __ ] do it
straight to the face like you got the
Porton you've got it man
yeah I like it I just it's yeah just
it's a look right you saw him like dude
listen to me let me tell you what
doesn't go away if your account went
away the memories of you yeah you look
like every other [ __ ] page sure I
mean I read every comment so I say that
I say I don't give a [ __ ] but you do but
I do a little bit guess what me too so
what do you do not give a [ __ ] but that
I don't like like I just it's 5149 I
give a [ __ ] so not I'm empathetic yes so
do you understand that I actually feel
bad for them and I do 100% I'm like yeah
I'm gonna beat it listen if I looked
like you I'd probably beat up some
people to like look punchline is very
simple
I actually feel bad like you're in a
place in your life where you have pain
and you're taking it out on me because
in this moment you deem that I have
happiness I feel bad
yeah
thank you yo if you're not following the
tank you're making a [ __ ] huge
mistake [ __ ] out [ __ ] you up you may
want to bring in her people he may want
to audit everybody we gotta think about
all those things because people
understood the money the the happiness
the fame the van if people really
understood what I was doing they would
they wouldn't believe it
so I actually spend no time on it I'd
lose I'd lose because you think I've
been trying to sell you something that
like it's only because I'm playing such
a long game mmm longer than anybody
actually like I should be on the size of
being 73 you know and having the body of
work you know so I understand but that
that's where that was going
[Music]
thank you yeah you know it's full time
thank you so much for your note that was
very sweet me on the day levy you're on
smile right what no yeah reason to smile
but you said you missed me that was
wrong I know but i but I absorbed it I'm
really excited I'm a man there's only
one there's literally only one reason
I'm here the singular reason I'm here is
I'm gonna take a selfie with this guy
and get him so many Instagram
I'm so honestly it's crazy what's going
on I appreciate Lu why you like it
because what even like the when I first
got to know you and when we met at like
new house or whatever people that like
it are people that like I actually think
it's strategy hmm disguised and like
motivation like I think the reason
people actually get results for me and
not from everybody else's is yeah I'm
very rah-rah and just in me it's Who I
am but like I actually build businesses
like this is my side hustle like I know
what the [ __ ] I'm talking about and like
the people that are smart like actually
like well like and they watch what I'm
doing more so than like get pumped like
you only live once yes you only live
once but if you actually understand why
I'm doing it it's my favorite cause it's
so improv sketch me first of all she
like rolled up on me in the car like it
was such a
the inspiration pretty damn throwing
down three words you're gonna die wait
wait wait
Tyler say something how long is your
snapchat i roaring through soy food I
enjoy the food I usually that atmosphere
[Music]
[Music]